haven't detected any cancer but
sometimes it cancer spots including in
my brain which is one millimeter which
is our tiny little bidding and so I'm
still taking treatments regularly mm-hmm
and I'll continue that until the doctors
tell me out on after a former President
Jimmy Carter reveals he's not entirely
cancer-free but since his diagnosis in
August our 39th president has been
determined to live by fully his Roslin
and her support helped you through this
support has helped me over the last
sixty nine years since we've been
married and everything I've ever tried
and of course when I was ill I thought I
was in my day at a time she was there
and she agreed with him and was excited
with me with it when I found out that my
metabolism responded well to the
treatment we didn't know ahead of time
whose world yeah but but i have my own
immune system seems to be responding our
affinity look fit as a fiddle well good
morning everybody T call up exclusively
with President Carter in Plains Georgia
at the painting Paula and a president
fundraiser that Paula that would be the
pride of Savannah miss Paula Deen I am
so thrilled alone for a long time and
she's been here I think the planes four
times and
the first two times I cooked whether the
second time was in my own kitchen I love
this teaching so how did you and he
become friends oh my gosh yes we've been
friends now Brooke maybe about 14 years
paula is on the second leg of her press
tour for her fifth teeth cookbook Paula
Deen cuts the fat you probably noticed a
change when paula was dancing with the
stars how much weight have you lost 42
pain Wow just by changing your diet yes
well I got down and dirty to start with
I mean I I took everything out of my
kitchen it was carb heavy Wow moderation
is a big word in my life now Brooke I
can't stand the word diet instead of a
stick of butter I'll just use a half
isn't it cause every little bit counts
yeah it makes a difference and how do
you feel you health wise and otherwise I
mean I'm great I'm great my type 2
diabetes my last blood work was 5.4 work
ok sure that's right which is great not
as good
you